[Music]
hello welcome back to conspiracy corner
where we talk about conspiracies and if
you are if you are like oh I don't know
if I believe this [ __ ] you get the [ __ ]
out of here cuz this ain't about that
this is all about it's really not it's
not about open discussion it's about
limited discussion and today we're gonna
talk about the alien species and
different alien races that exist the
grace the reptilians the reptilians man
the reptilians are [ __ ] wild I mean
all reptilians employees and dude
someone sent me a PDF that had like the
Bible of every alien that's ever visited
earth and like what time frame they
visited earth so what else is there
besides reptilian I can't remember all
of them because they actually didn't
even make it through the PDF there's a
humanoids - there's one that's like
they're like the Amazon of the Amazonian
type of one where they're all like
they're perfect specimens are like
beautiful beautiful [ __ ] people but
they're giant and so they're giant
before and tall [ __ ] and the
Vikings and they're like just like
golden Camino ends yeah and they're just
beautiful and then they left because
Earth was getting [ __ ] up by this
other by the reptilian aliens that came
and they're like nah [ __ ] this [ __ ]
we're not even gonna fight this world
Viking gods with the Greek gods like
they were based off of those that raise
you in gods and then ask thanks because
they know minds are a sex which one's
built the pyramids for you anything both
ends like a boat did they also mind that
they also were influenced by alien yeah
pharaohs were like hybrids yep yep
that's what they had to have that's why
Hercules is a half-breed then we got
them all basically cuz uh there's a
humanoid once that were supposed to be
descendants of there's the reptilians
that look like lizards the Nordics the
oh yeah the Nordics and they're supposed
to be the Viking go green men um is that
one where some people can see them and
some people can't like at best rules I
swear didn't know so in my family
lineage like one of the one of the like
fables or whatever my grandpa could
apparently see all the little green men
and he had like magic powers did you
grab my smoke a lot of weed - I don't
know
EMT he's not helium but like there's
like stories of people being able to
turn into animals and stuff like that
and with him like he could see the
little green men but and he could pass
that power on to like his next Akane
that's so cool did you know that magic
actually pass over because my brother
can do the double joining where you can
jump rope with himself do that jump did
jump generations cuz like my mom can't
do it by my grandma can do that looks
like he looks like a freaking alien when
you see the show like pops we does it
and then pops back again so your show we
got we got the Grey's which are the app
looking fools
they're either short or really tall and
they don't have ears they have the big
eyes they're your when you think aliens
that's what they are
okay so the reptilians they look like
lizard people and they could shape-shift
yeah there that's what I heard they're
shaped you can tell like their eyes
blink the different way sci-fi trope
comes from like it was a sci-fi Trevor
Berbick trillions it's not a trope it's
not true it's real and equality Beyonce
means completely yeah dude have you ever
been on YouTube and you look up like
people are like oh I saw a shape-shifter
on camera it's just like usually like
the theory is they're people that are
kind of prominent in our society so
newscasters yeah exactly like people
celebrities certain celebrities and
stuff they position themselves so they
have a lot of influence and so like the
newscasters a lot of like YouTube videos
so be like I found a shapeshifter online
and it's always looks like a hillbilly
[ __ ] but he's like recording with this
camera but it was like iPhone and and he
plays it back he's like well you see you
guys you see is eyes blink it didn't
blink on human I never see no human
you know what you guys are [ __ ]
[ __ ] because I believe in this [ __ ]
so [ __ ] you guys [ __ ] you so I'm trying
to go down the damn Lisbon so we have
the grace right this is for the people
that have never heard of this show oh
yeah sorry get excited where's the
corner the grace but grace the greys are
the typical alien more useful than they
look like and small help build the UFOs
Jenner there's supposedly they're the
ones that help the humans build UFOs
we're [ __ ] joking around too much
let's go down to the basics okay let's
start from the beginning one the great
race what do they look like they look
like ants big eyes whatever there's tall
ones they're short ones right okay now
and then we have the reptilians who are
the lizard people shapeshifters yeah the
shapeshifters they look like snake
iguana noise iguanas right and then we
have the Nordics which are the Viking
gods or after them right you're extra
tall extra blonde it's like they look
like yeah yeah but they look like tall
beautiful humans honey I thought you
were supposed to be like the descent
like why people are supposed to be
descendants of them like genetically
modified that's doors think he-man or
her man in some cultures it's a man
Hamas no not a mother but and I think
that's basically it and then there's
little green man yeah yeah that's mostly
that's not supposed to be with us no
there's like hundreds of species that
have visited but most of them say the
[ __ ] away cuz there's there's like a
like in this PDF or the PDF gave rope
but I thought it was interesting I was
like even if this decides like science
fiction and like not meant to be taken
seriously you guys are so afraid of mean
comments right now you can't talk about
this conspiracy without saying how its
silly it is I think you guys are silly
here's the thing can I just stop finish
my [ __ ] thing about how there's five
races of aliens were fighting right now
on earth to protect Earth like they're
trying to protect therefore that's what
I'm trying to figure out there's an aqua
one but oh yeah
city Atlantis that's when they were yeah
they live down in the sea and that's
where you see like some footage has been
caught we're like a spaceship like shoot
out from the [ __ ] ocean like a UFO
well like shoot outside anyone died and
there was like um the Navy has found
like really fast moving like look a
vehicle that's moving like not
submarines but like there's something
fast moving under the water and then
they disappear off the radar right and
it's not like a blue whale or dolphin I
don't know I want Steve on this one
because look look when you think about
it when people start talking about
aliens like weird it even come from in
the first place
somebody must have witnessed it in order
for these stories to be passed out just
saying and they all look the same right
they all have similar features we at
least have some form of like an image of
it I feel like there's more than five
though it doesn't matter if I protected
earth right that's what it's really
about is is about what they're here for
and what their plan is right that's
their plan
the reptilians want to take over
everything they want to take over
they're all battling with each other if
the reptilians are warring with the
greys the grades are kind of protecting
us and that's why we haven't had a major
nuclear war
well yeah right so they've they have
reportedly they have gone to our missile
silos and like [ __ ] with our tech a
couple of times like that's what a lot
of government insiders have so like
there would have been atomic war
breakout between Russia and us but then
they stopped it that's why the Cold War
was going on because they just kept
[ __ ] weather news that's what some
people it was this testing site where
they all ended up being duds xx duds in
a row and they and there were reports
that there were lights that went over
the you humans stop that this stuff they
were all dead after World War two or
during World War two there was a UFO
those spotted over Los Angeles yeah and
they call it the Battle of Los Angeles
and there's still ammunition that you
can find like on beaches in certain
places from that night where they were
firing at something in the sky I heard
there was a bunch of lights and they
thought it was an attack by Japan or
something so they just thought of
shooting like a [ __ ] in there
and then it was just nothing nothing a
battle that's so cool I didn't know we
were
site yeah the dude who played to face he
was in it to face he he say that was a
[ __ ] movie it was a good idea for a
movie yeah based in reality that's crazy
so I mean you know you guys what do you
guys watch ancient aliens yeah
he owns the one is that the I who all
know he's like aliens man yeah so their
theory is that they've been here for
like all these ancient structures and
all that it was built by them and they
genetically modified us right yeah and
there's pictures in the Bible that
looked like UFOs but they called them
angels and there's tic-tac there's
tic-tac shaped UFOs and different UFOs
throughout like art and in the
Renaissance era and all kinds of shits
[ __ ] but it's not just like like they
were showing these things in the sky
with with people inside almost all
ancient cultures has um something about
do you think Jesus was alien that's
another thing he could have been about
that water yeah he died one came back
and then ascended and send it into
heaven he never sent it into things I
think he was the world's first superhero
no there's a bunch of super yeah it's
like looking back to ancient Egypt and
stuff like going further and further
back like you have a lot of people that
are like just [ __ ] like God like a
Moses part in dead sea and all that sort
of stuff he's gonna greet the Greek gods
Jesus was did some bitchin street magic
too yeah he was a David Blaine of his
time he yeah he could take your card and
then he could have it tattooed on his
arm yeah that's one of his premier one
of his many candles got a whole bunch of
people drunk on his wide I heard you
made a lot of fish out of nowhere a lot
of bread toots you said you have a
reptilian story yeah I got a [ __ ]
story about a about a friend that I knew
from like [ __ ] elementary school and
stuff so I haven't seen this guy in
[ __ ] like five or six years and I'm
like washing my car outside my house
it's like it's starting to rain - and so
I'm like I'm gonna take this in and
everything like that also he comes
running down my hill and I'm like is
that I think that guy then he comes is
like yo what's up dude how's it going
I'm like um it's going alright how are
you doing I haven't seen you in he's
like yeah dude I was just I would just
up there can I get a ride home I'm like
sure yeah cuz he's like I just live
right over the hill and so I'm like
alright whatever so I like start driving
him back and he's he's like yeah dude
man things have been crazy recently man
like I've been going on a lot of
retreats to like figure out how to like
you know manage my chakra and stuff and
yet like a lot manage my job a lot of
cyber spirit or throw and it's been like
real crazy man and like yeah I was
abducted like two weeks ago and it's
it's been crazy ever since I got back
and I'm like oh okay looked at two years
ago weeks ago two weeks even sooner yeah
but he was just like yeah dude it's real
crazy cuz like you know about like the
reptilians right I'm like no one of the
reptilians man he's like such a dude so
they're like there's like a giant
underground like all of Los Angeles is
one big underground subterranean base
for them and they're just like
controlling stuff all underneath it and
they're basically like every major like
celebrity and stuff ah you mean like the
president yeah dude that's what I'm
saying man like if you look at his eyes
like they blink sideways and stuff and
I'm like okay and this just kept on
going on for like I swear to God an hour
like I got him in front of like the
house that he just kept talking just
kept going and I was like is this is
this where I died this is the moment
where I like where the drugs was he
doing yeah
truth drugs you know you know in all
seriousness I feel like he's off his
meds right like because I know that he's
I had some mental health issues and
stuff but like like it was crazy hearing
all of like the online conspiracy
theories out of like someone's mouth in
person somebody that I know from like so
far back and stuff what if homeless
people really knew mental house just
opens up this channel like the crazy and
then like all this street these other
streams are coming edge attraction of
like you get this magic ability but this
is the detraction you have everybody
thinks you're crazy yeah like that was
that was like a scream was definitely
like what he was saying like he just
kept on saying all this stuff like like
we would talk about history and stuff
like that he was like yeah and then you
know and you remember the great battle
of like you know the 60s board during
that time or he's talking he's just
talking about all these like giant
conflicts and stuff like that between
like aliens and like ghosts and stuff
like
oh no which one which one was the great
battle have to know these no I lose it
was so dense that I don't like attention
dude I was he was crazy listening to
know who's [ __ ] know never everyone's
in an agreement and someone has
something different they're the crazy
one so if everyone believes in aliens
and everything and then one person's
like I don't know about this they'd be
[ __ ] great now we're talkin yeah I
don't know I would just wouldn't shy
away from the idea that I love hearing
it like that's my favorite [ __ ] part
is like hearing things and be like that
could happen that could happen that
could happen have you heard of the
Denver Airport
oh yeah the secret military base or
whatever underneath it I'm about to go
to the airport like to see military but
probably loominatee aka aliens the
reptilians okay okay could you go to
dinner yeah I'm going in two days when
you go there yeah look at all the
[ __ ] decorations there's a mural of
like everyone on fire like there's like
demonic gargoyles it's [ __ ] weird and
there's there's Masonic [ __ ] [ __ ]
everywhere like the symbols of the
Masons of the Freemasons this is [ __ ]
every and there's like places where they
were even the employees can't go and
they go deep underground and supposedly
there's like a giant bunker that people
could live underground for like years
well is the Mile High City so I'm sure
they keep who chooses the yard the
interior decorator yeah like what helped
the Illuminati believe that if you have
symbols in public if you have like all
of your stuff in public it gives it more
power which is why one Beyonce is like
this people like to look at they're
doing the aluminum we need to do this
because we need more subscribers for JK
news we symbolize we need but most
importantly yeah sorry that's our real
sense pierce out partners
[Music]